Professor Steve girvin for those of you
who don't know him uh just a legendary
Professor here at Yale uh and uh someone
who's been a great partner to us in
terms of yqi and its connections uh to
the shrimp program at Jackson he's yells
Eugene Higgins professor of physics and
applied physics he's previously served
as Deputy Provost to the University for
Science and Technology Deputy Provost
for research and his scholarship has
focused on theoretical studies of
quantum many particle systems uh
interests and atomic physics Quantum
Optics Quantum computation and in
addition to teaching at Yale he has
served as the founding director of
Brookhaven National Laboratories
co-design Center for Quantum Advantage
where he remains an active member and
this is a major national effort funded
by the department of energy to
accelerate transformational advances in
Quantum science and to build the tools
necessary to create scalable quantum
computer systems so in terms of what
that means for Global Affairs and very
delighted to hand it over to Steve to
introduce other colleagues I know we
have some folks here from uh Professor
Shruti puri's class as well so welcome
to all of you and I think this will be a
fun session so appreciate it Steve thank
you very much this is uh I hope this
will be fun uh so I have some help uh
try to sing as a graduate student
Kevin Smith and Jack Price are more
stocks and we have some uh some
physicists here from shuki's class and
um so the first thing is uh the you know
the most important sentence you can
learn as a scientist and to succeed is I
don't understand so
you know we talk this stuff every day
and we have a kind of inside baseball
lingo if I accidentally use some
uh or quantum mechanics is just too
strange for you stick your hand up and
say I don't understand and we have time
and I want you know I'd rather uh
uncover a little then cover a lot
and so I also promise uh we won't talk
about this stuff
and uh please you know just don't be shy
and please interrupt
so
um so I thought I'd the way this is
gonna work is
um
or we hope it's gonna work is I'll I'll
give I have a slide deck
and the first part is just kind of you
know what's quantum about and what's
going on these days and then we're going
to talk about a specific protocol
for encrypting Communications
in a way that can't be broken without
violating the laws of physics so it's a
physical based encryption and we're
gonna you have some handouts we're going
to do some little exercises so I'll I'll
say some stuff that'll sound complicated
and you'll get a chance to practice it
it'll seem easy then we'll move on I
hope that's the plan okay
so um
so there's you know there's a sort of
second quantum Revolution going on right
now and I want to just give you a little
uh
background about that so first I I have
a few places where I say vocabulary just
to make sure I'm using uh words in the
way that you understand
and
um so when we say classical mechanics uh
uh we mean the things that Galileo and
Newton did in the late 1600s
and uh it's it's an extremely successful
theory of mechanical motion of the Moon
of falling apples footballs planets uh
and when I say quantum mechanics or the
quantum theory that's a more complete
theory invented in the 20th century
that explains all of this
but this fails for very small objects
and quantum theory applies to Tiny
objects like atoms and electrons and
individual particles of light photons
okay
and so
quantum theory is uh the single most
successful uh theory in in all of the
physical sciences a theory is you know
if you have
Evolution debates you know theory is
actually the highest uh adjective not
the lowest uh it means that it's been
fully uh
confirmed by experiment with too many
many digits of accuracy so quantum
theory describes Behavior at Atomic
scales and now or larger scales even
millimeter scales
in some of the qubits the quantum bits
that we've built and it's extremely
strange and mysterious and
counter-intuitive
uh picture of the world in which
you have to use language like particles
act like waves and waves act like
particles
and they're very counter-intuitive
effects
um that the you can prepare exactly the
same experiment over and over again and
get different random results each time
even though it's exactly the same
there's a certain built-in
ineluctable Randomness in the results
and then there's this thing that
Einstein hated spooky action at a
distance
entanglement
which for which the uh was discovered a
long time ago but for which really solid
experiments have only been done
uh in the last four years and are the
subject of this year's Nobel Prize in
physics
so Einstein uh you know invented a lot
of the ideas of quantum mechanics but he
hated it
and he couldn't deal he just couldn't
stand the fact that there should be
non-deterministic results there should
be yeah ineluctable Randomness and he
said uh God does not play dice but
modern physicists
um like to say that the irony is that it
was Einstein of Dave God the the diocese
he really gave us a lot of the ideas
that found uh founded the quantum theory
so the first Quantum Revolution the sort
of invention of the quantum theory uh
beginning more than 100 years ago
people were physicists were just
thinking about
um
very basic things about reality and
electrons and atoms that light and there
were it's just curiosity driven
fundamental research I want to put a
plug in that for you future policy
leaders
um there were no conceivable
applications for these kind of uh things
uh thinking about things that were
invisible tiny atoms and so forth
and and yet
it led to the technological revolution
of the 20th century it led to the
transistor the laser the atomic clock
which in turn led to the global
positioning system
and the inventors of quantum mechanics
did not foresee these Quantum devices
and even the more practical
Engineers who invented these Quantum
devices and did not foresee their
applications which are you know
all around you and yet invisible right
so
uh you know here's a picture of Charlie
towns in 1953 with this big clunky uh
physics experiment that was one of the
first atomic clocks uh that it's hard to
imagine that today you know I hold in my
hand a gadget that knows by listening to
Transmissions from satellites where it
is on the what time it is to about a
nanosecond and where it is on the earth
to a few meters of precision it's just
incredible
uh there's the first transistor 1947 is
about this big you can see beautiful uh
Blobs of solder and wires and that's
incredibly ugly uh and uh those uh uh uh
people who invented that could not
foresee this
and the you know the central processing
unit in your uh in your computer and
they certainly could not foresee the
number of transistors being produced in
the world today
any idea how many transistors are made
in one second every day of every year
more than 20 trillion transistors per
second
it's a good thing they're small
otherwise we'd run out of stuff
so you know the scaling
from one at a centimeter scale to 20 uh
you know there was about roughly 20
billion in in a iPhone
uh it's just amazing and very hard to
foresee so we hope that this same thing
is going to happen with the second
quantum Revolution but we have a long
long way to go
so we've recently come to understand
that these Quantum devices aren't very
Quantum they don't have the full power
that's available to Quantum machines
and in particular there's much more
power for processing in the
communicating information
than we realized
and so
the new idea which is driving this
second quantum Revolution is that the
very strangest aspects of quantum theory
this uncertainty and Randomness which
I'll I'll I'll show you some examples uh
they're not bugs like it seems like to a
classical physicist no you do an
experiment exactly the same way every
time when you get a random result that
seems bad I can't predict as well as I
could before
You can predict the probabilities of
different results but you can't predict
the results of any experiment it seems
like a bug but in fact it can be a
feature that we can use in Technologies
and in fact that Randomness is going to
be key to our Quantum encryption
protocol that we're going to work
through today for securely transmitting
information
so
um
this is a I think the final slide on
this so there's this revolution underway
I tried to explain we couldn't predict
the consequences of the first one so uh
I don't think we can predict the
consequences of this one it has the
potential to fizzle out because the
technology is just too difficult at this
point or it has the potential to
you know perhaps be as revolutionary as
the as the tech revolution of the 20th
century and it involves sort of three
things Quantum materials with novel
properties
Quantum sensing we under measurement is
a very important part of quantum
mechanics the role of an observer is
special when you observe something you
change it that's going to be part of our
encryption protocol also and we've
learned much more about how to the
ultimate limits of making Precision
measurements and those are being used
both for fundamental physics uh things
like seeing black hole mergers producing
tiny vibrations of space-time which we
can now measure and it's also the start
you know can be used in intelligence
scattered
you can use a thing which is kind of
like an atomic clock to fly over a
mountain and see whether there's a
tunnel inside because there's less
gravity than you expect because there's
a tunnel there uh and then uh
information processing is uh
is very important and what's a lot of
What's Done in this institute is
centered around Quantum building
computers based on the principles of
quantum mechanics but our discussion
today is going to be about communication
uh security and encryption
okay so uh the technology is not here
yet we're in the very earliest uh days I
wouldn't say we're in the earliest part
of the hype cycle but we're uh we
probably headed for some uh troughs of
this disillusionment before we uh
finally get this technology to work
but lots and lots of money is being
invested uh in these Technologies uh now
because of their great potential
okay so uh I'm gonna pause here we're
gonna start our discussion of the main
topic today uh secure communication but
maybe if you have questions now
uh what I've said so far I'm happy to
take that
yeah
um so you were describing the first
Quantum Revolution that it was First
Fundamental research with that was
curiosity driven and then applications
have followed so in the second
revolution is it following like kind of
a similarity absolutely yeah I mean the
um
you know the the people that started
thinking about these questions roughly
30 years ago
were uh
Cirrus completely disconnected to expand
the realities of experiments and uh
uh slowly they started getting some
interesting ideas other people started
paying attention and then people started
thinking about well maybe there's a way
to actually make these ideas work and
practice and there's this huge effort
going on now
um
uh making the technology better and
better but still we've made huge
progress but we have a tremendous way to
go before it becomes let's say
economically or uh
important but we're on that same route
yeah
good yeah
um
Jackson Mas student or the one year
program in an army uh and for the
concept of flying over a mountain and
being able to detect the different level
of gravity you said is there a phrase
that I can use to research that uh
you can probably try gravitational
anomaly I I can send you the name of a
person if that doesn't work yeah
hi Josh
hi um can you explain like how tradition
because my understanding that
transistors are really binary yeah
yeah so
um so uh transistors can encode
classical I'm going to talk about this
classical this there are switches that
can be on or off or have a voltage or
not have a voltage and uh that's that's
how classical fits are manipulated in
your computer I'm going to talk about
how Quantum bits are different yeah
okay all right so
um so some more vocabulary so the uh
when you write a paper in communication
and encryption you you you always use
that Alice is sending a message to Bob
these are the uh these are the terms of
Art in the field and there's an
eavesdropper named e
okay so the problem is Alice has a
secret message she wants to send to Bob
over some Communication channel Radio
optical fiber telephone whatever
uh and she wants to uh
let make sure that Bob is the only
person in the world that gets the
message and knows knows what it says the
eavesdropper may have access you know
may uh
to pick an example uh from the 19
60s there may have been a submarine that
went into the Bering Sea and may have
dropped a bell Labs uh magnetometer down
around a little undersea cable and may
have picked up uh all the signals from
the magnetic fields emanating from the
currents in those wires
my uncle may have been on that boat
so there are ways to intercept uh uh
the signals and see what they are so you
have to you don't want to send them in
plain text you want to
encode them in some secret codes
so
um
so but before we like start talking
about that we have to kind of Define
what you know and quantify what is
information okay well information is
surprised
uh if I tell you
um the sun rose this morning it's not
much of a surprise right information is
I tell you something you didn't know
before okay
and if I tell you the answer to a yes no
question
that you didn't know before and kind of
prior to this you
you had no idea you know you had just
estimated it's a 50 50 probability I'm
going to hear yes or no that's receiving
one bit of information
uh binary digits and it can be
represented by true or false or yes or
no or in a computer by a zero or a one
okay so you can uh
uh
another example is and we have some
coins here today we're going to be using
we want them all back uh
so Alice slips a coin nobody knows
whether it's going to land heads or
tails and she reveals which it was
that's one bit of information not
necessarily a useful one but it's a bit
of information if she tells Bob gets one
bit
so a bit straying is just a collection
of uh ones and zeros and in this case uh
it it's a byte it contains eight bits of
information
okay so what can you do with these bit
strings well you could if you sent
strings of five bits
you could encode the alphabet in let's
say in English so a could be all zeros B
could be four zeros and a one C could be
zero zero zero one zero uh those of you
that might know about binary numbers
those are the binary numbers
representing zero one two three four
five
we need a
five bits to represent uh 32 characters
so you've got the 26 letters and you can
do a few numbers also
or you could you could have a a code
book that used to be you know literally
books on Navy ships uh with uh different
messages so here are some very famous
messages from history telegrams
and then you could represent this
message by this bit string zero zero
zero zero so probably nobody here knows
where that comes from
the Italian Navigator has landed in the
new world the natives are friendly it's
not Columbus
it's Enrico Fermi in Chicago got the
first nuclear pile operating in the
Manhattan Project this was the telegram
that was sent to Washington
so itself isn't coded right it's in
English but
this was pre-arranged to me that the
atomic
uh
file worked
probably you know what this is
50 years ago okay landing on the moon
uh and this is probably easy to guess
but maybe uh formal rights sending a
telegram to his father in Ohio saying
they were coming home for Christmas and
uh
the airplane worked
okay so uh if you had such a big code
book
if it had a thousand and 24 messages you
only need 10 bits to encode them all
because 10 digits can represent all the
numbers between 0 and 1023.
if you had 20 bits you can send a
million different messages
it's very very efficient
okay and as long as only Alice and Bob
have copies of the code book you're fine
but of course uh
if people start correlating the messages
with what they see you know if there's a
message that's attacked every time they
send bit strings you know one one one
one one and there's a an attack at the
following dot you can kind of start to
guess what's going on
so it's a very complicated cat and mouse
game of offense and defense in uh
signals
okay so here's the the transistor uh
rather than a transistor I have just a
some mechanical uh switch and you can
store one bit of information in the
position of the switch if the switch is
off so the light bulb is not shining uh
we'll call that zero if the switch is
closed so that circuit the current can
flow from the battery through the light
bulb we'll call that a one and you can
transmit that bit to other people in the
form of of uh the light coming from the
light bulb so information is physical we
like to say it's always transmitted uh
stored in and transmitted by physical
systems so these instead of these
mechanical switches you have electrical
switches
that are controlled by by electricity in
the form of transistors in your
computers
Okay so
uh there's one provable
provably secure method in classical
communication meaning with ordinary uh
forgets uh to to do secure information
transition transmission and that's the
one one-time pad encryption using a
random key so Alice and Bob have a pad
of paper and it had they flipped coins
or something and they have uh
written down a completely random string
of bits zeros and ones
they've also
encoded their English language plain
text message as a string of zeros and
ones that's called the plain text
sure
and then
that text is encrypted by the following
rule uh
uh if if the key is zero take the plain
text and just copy it down here if the
key is one copy the opposite of what is
here if it's a one you put a zero if
it's a zero you put a one
okay so it's as if there are two ways to
let's think of these as I don't know yes
and no there are two ways to encode yes
and no zero is yes no is one or the
other way around and for each bit Alice
is flipping a coin to decide which code
to use
so once you've done that
this this string is completely random
there is no way that you can even if you
intercept it
no way to know what it means unless you
have this key
so if Bob has if Alice has this key and
Bob has a copy of it Bob can go in the
other direction and decrypt very easily
he looks at the key and applies the same
rule if it's a zero just copy it back up
here if it's a one
copy the opposite so the two rules just
can't applying it twice just cancels the
effect of incursion does that make sense
so it's provably you know the weak Link
in all of this is always the people but
mathematically if the people are
behaving themselves mathematically you
can prove this is perfectly secure as
long as the key is completely random
there's no pattern to the zeros and ones
it has to be as long as the message
because you have to encrypt each single
fit
and you can never reuse it
because there'll be correlations between
subsequent messages if you do
and so that's why it's called a one-time
path
so that's that's basic classical
encryption
this is provably secure but it has a
huge problem
the key distribution problem
the secret key
uh if Bob doesn't have it
Alice has to send it to Bob and it's
it's a bit string that's the same length
as the message
you can't send the message securely how
could you send the secret key securely
so maybe Bob uh uh you know went back to
uh somewhere in Virginia and and copied
down what she had on Alice had on her
one time pad and kept it with him
hopefully for safe keeping and nobody
saw it then it'll work
but uh if if Alice and Bob are in
different corners of the globe and
haven't been able to do that
you're stuck because you can't
distribute the secret key it's the same
problem as secretly Distributing the
message that makes sense
okay so Eve Eve could intercept
the telephone call
internet transmission the optical fiber
transmission
uh and and see what either the message
or the secret key are and then just send
it on or observe it as it goes by or
send it on to Bob
and Bob is none the wiser that the
eavesdropper is there and has
compromised the channel
so it turns out there's a solution to
the key distribution problem if you use
a Quantum version of bits okay
and this is a protocol that was invented
uh by my friend Charlie Bennett and the
colleague brazar in 1984. it was based
on an older idea called Quantum money
well invented by Steve Wiesner who was
stuck son of the Wiesner who was the MIT
president
um didn't didn't uh couldn't get it
published until much later after these
these guys had done their protocol okay
so we're gonna go through this there's
lots to unpack here you got to find out
what is a Quantum fit
et cetera et cetera but here's here's I
just want to do the big picture
um so uh here's Alice in the quantum
Institute and this is Bob Bob is it up
the street in the Jackson School Eve is
somewhere in between and there are two
ways we can communicate there's a public
Channel meaning
um it's a telephone or or internet
connection something that's potentially
whose security is not guaranteed okay
and then there's a a Quantum Channel
which I'm going to have to explain to
you what it is
uh and Eve Eve has access potentially to
both channels and both channels are
going to be part of the protocol
so there's a part that uh you don't need
Quantum things to send you can just talk
over the telephone
um and anybody can listen in and it can
still be secure that's an interesting
aspect of it because it has this Quantum
Channel okay and we're gonna try to be
consistent in our color coding so green
will mean public channel uh anybody it
means classical and anybody could in
principle be listening in and then the
red will mean Quantum Channel and blue
will mean classical or not Quant
okay so here's the here's the basic idea
I want you to hold on to as we March
through the complicated Parts uh in
quantum mechanics If You observe that is
measure the state of my Quantum system
it changes
and
uh it's it's the act of looking at
something like Shining Light on it and
bouncing it to your eye but something is
so tiny and fragile that's shining a
little light on it changes it that's
roughly the idea
and this BB 84 protocol
it's uh set up to detect the presence of
the eavesdropper who is observing what's
being sent on the quantum Channel
they're going to be Quantum bits which I
have to explain to you that are sent
along here and if Eve looks at them
makes a measurement of them to see uh
what secret key is being sent to Bob
uh they will uh unwittingly
modify the state of those bits and
corrupt what the information that's
being sent about
but there's part of the protocol is that
Bob and Alice will be able to detect
that that happened
okay and then call it off if there's
somebody there okay so again information
is still physical even if it's Quantum
information
instead of storing information in a you
know a big written zero or one on a
piece of paper or a switch being open or
closed we're going to store information
in maybe the states of a single atom or
a single particle of light a photon
and quantum mechanics teaches us that
the energy levels of an atom are
discrete they're quantized they're not
they don't vary continuously and you can
label them then with integers and the
lowest two you can call States zero and
one so if the energy is the lowest
possible maybe that represents bit value
zero
and the first excited state represents
the value one and there are many
physical systems that can hold this at
us molecules ions photons here at Yale
we work a lot with electrical circuits
superconducting electrical circuits even
small mechanical oscillators can have
contacts
okay well Quantum bits are very very
very strange and mysterious so we have
to you know fasten your seat belts and
we have to think about these very
non-intuitive things so in addition to
having the possibility of being in state
zero or state one
there's an infinite number a continuous
range of States called uh superposition
states which are in some sense
intermediate between zero and one
and yet if you measure which uh State
it's in it always comes out to be zero
or one
so for the purposes of this protocol
we're going to use only four states
and we're gonna they're called
polarization States and we're going to
represent them by arrows so the qubit
the atom or whatever is holding the
qubit the arrow can point up or down or
to the right or to the left those are
the only four states that we're going to
talk about if you look online at videos
about this protocol they usually talk
about uh Photon polarizations and they
use these uh lines with arrows on both
ends and slopes uh I like this those
four symbols but it just doesn't matter
there's four four symbols okay
and
uh there's there's one bit of
information in here a zero or one and
yet there are four states and it's
because they represent two different
ways to put the zero and one in there
just like in the one-time pad
you could start with a zero in the plain
text and represent it either as a zero
or one in the encrypted text randomly
switching between the encodings
there are two kinds of encoding just
like the the secret key in the one-time
pad can be a zero or one those are two
different encodings we're going to talk
about a z basis encoding or an X basis
in the coding and so uh if Alice
wants to send a zero
to Bob she can choose the Z encoding and
send him an up Arrow
or she could choose the X encoding and
send him an arrow pointing to the right
she wants to send a one and she randomly
chooses this encoding she sends a down
arrow
that she randomly chooses the accent
coding she sends a left Arrow okay
so the blue things are the classical
bits values she wants to send to Bob and
the red things are the quantum states of
our bits
all right so I think we have an exercise
now
the conversion table is at the top
and the exercise on the left
is you want to take the classical bit
and then code it in
the Z encoding into one of those four
arrows or this a zero and put it in the
X encoding with one of those four arrows
and on the right you want to do the
reverse process here are the arrows you
want to put zeros and ones here
that makes sense
so take your time feel free to ask
questions we have uh experts in the
audience who's standing by to assist you
effect
I think the next slide is the answer
okay so you can check your
answers there it's okay to be wrong and
ask questions about why you're wrong
that's allowed
that's the other important sentence for
every scientist I tell my students when
first thing when you get out of bed in
the morning say to yourself could I be
wrong
the easiest person to fool is yourself
doing science
so in the one-time pad Alice had flipped
a bunch of coins and had the the secret
key and use those to randomly change the
encoding for
in each bit here Alice is going to do
something different she's going to
randomly switch between the Z encoding
where the bits are up and down and the X
encoding where they are left and right
the polarizations okay
now you say well well that's not going
to help because Bob can just look at the
arrow and see whether it's up down right
or left
well it doesn't work that way the rules
of quantum mechanics don't let you know
uh both of those things the rules of
mechanic quantum mechanics say when Bob
gets a qubit and wants to see what its
value is he has to make a decision
he has to choose
to see what the value is in the Z
polarization to make what we call a c
measurement or X but he can't do both so
if you know where a particle is you
can't know how fast it's going or vice
versa this is like that if you know what
the value of the bit is when you measure
it in make a z I'm going to show you a
picture of a z measurement when you ask
what is the value of the qubit in the Z
basis
you remove the possibility that you can
find out what it is in the X basis so
it's like position and momentum yeah
there's a Heisenberg circuit principle
connect
yeah and there's the choice for each and
every bit or is it each and every bit
we're gonna Bob has to measure and he
has to make a choice because he uh
you'll see
um uh you know I'm going to go through
it so keep asking questions but but the
the
first the thing you have to know right
now is he has a choice he can either
measures in the Z basis or the X basis
now we're going to see what what does
that imply what happens when he does
that okay so here's uh Bob has uh some
setting on his measurement apparatus he
can set it to Z or X
okay so he sets it to Z and it happens
that Alice has sent him a bunch of bits
in the Z basis so you see the arrows are
up and down
okay what happens well
they just go through and uh they're
presented to Bob uh with
um uh you know this this represents a
zero there's another zero and there's a
one okay so the when Bob looks at the
state it doesn't get messed up or
changed and Bob correctly learns the bit
value that Alice sent okay
something strange happens if he chooses
the wrong encoding if he decides to make
an X measurement
when the the polarization is in the Z
Direction he gets random results
sometimes it's pointing to the right
sometimes it's pointing to the left
and so and but he doesn't know that he's
randomly changed the state this would
have been the result uh if if this
polarization had been to the right and
passed through the measurement then he
got this unchanged he doesn't know that
he changed it there's no way to tell it
so the bottom line is he's unsure what
Alice said
okay
it's unpredictable
and you know so there's this strange
thing in quantum mechanics and the
results are random
but it's not like you know I have an
envelope like uh
try to flip the coin put a zero or one
and a piece of paper in the envelope and
handed it to me and there's definitely
either a zero or one in the envelope
when I open it I see what it is that is
when you open it you see what you get in
quantum mechanics you get what you see
you it doesn't have a value neither zero
or one
but when you look the act of looking
brings a value into existence zero one
and if you ask is it pointing in the X
direction is it pointing horizontally it
always is
sometimes to the right sometimes the
left
if you ask uh is it pointing up or down
it always is when you measure all right
so it works the other way too uh if uh
if your mom chooses to make an X
measurement and he happens to receive
bits that are pointing left and right it
works fine
okay he correctly learns the classical
value that Alice said but if he makes a
z measurement on qubits that were
encoded
in the X basis
he accidentally and unknowingly randomly
changes them okay
all right so how can we use these facts
about nature which I just have to ask
you to accept at face value because
they're completely insane
um Alice is gonna how can we use it so
Alice is going to randomly switch he
flips a coin and decides whether to use
the Z basis or the X basis and she does
not tell Bob in advance what what she's
going to do okay so there's no need for
you know
communication of that that would be the
same as the key right
so
um so Bob doesn't know if Alice chose to
encode in the Z basis of the X basis so
he doesn't know which basis to use in
order to measure to get the right answer
so he just guesses
okay you could guess Z every time or X
every time or he could flip a coin
and about half the time you'll by chance
uh guess correctly in half the time
incorrectly
okay
and so if he guesses correctly he gets
the correct bit value if he guesses
incorrectly he gets a random bit value
okay
so there's there's a
even though it's random it might
actually
it might you know it was supposed to be
zero maybe it comes out still so there's
the 50 percent
but he guesses incorrectly only 50 of
the time so that's where the 25 is
okay we need two uh two volunteers
uh who wants to be YouTube famous you'll
be recorded and plus it so if you don't
want your image to be there uh so you're
Alice you're Bob you need to uh uh
compose a secret key okay so we're gonna
flip the coin if it's heads right zero
if it's Tails right one thing so I flip
it here you can do it hence is zero I
think I said okay
no
so by the way some of you are going to
be
I told you it was the people
one more okay I can't count okay so now
you have the secret key now you need to
uh let's see you have to do the encoding
using the table over there okay
okay measurement the cell will secretly
check if you did it right
good
all right good all right congratulations
okay all right oh yeah okay so I'm I'm
the person that uh makes the measurement
happen and uh it came out
um
according to the right
well yeah you can decode it to ones and
zeros at the same time if you want yes
[Music]
okay and then what'd you choose for The
Second One X again
okay that was a mistake
uh tails
uh that's a one
oh that's an up
all right
it's an edge
left
oh yeah okay okay sorry yeah
we should be doing this so you guys can
see all right what'd you pick for the
Third One X again okay
so you're okay so it's pointing to the
left you got that left doesn't work you
don't know that you've got it right I'm
just
okay what's the last one z z okay
it's up
it's different okay all right what
what'd you get for the message zero one
one zero okay
so uh you you got that one wrong
and actually how many questions so
um
this you chose the wrong base this year
and the wrong basis there but you
accidentally got the bit right
here you chose the wrong basis and got
the bit wrong here you chose the correct
phase of some got it right okay
so it's not guaranteed could have gotten
lucky
and gotten it exactly right or gotten
them all wrong so so here's what
happened just now Alice sent Bob in this
case we only did four but let's say
here's a whole long string of quantum
fits
she here's the classical bit she wants
to send
here's the encoding basis that she
randomly chose for each one okay and so
classical bit in the Z basis that's an
up Barrel classical bit of zero and the
X basis that's a right arrow classic fit
in one and the Z basis that's a down
arrow Etc okay so these are the quantum
bits that Alice is sending to Bob
Bob randomly chooses what basis to
measure in
and gets about half of them right the
first three are right the ones in red
are wrong does that make sense okay so
then uh when Bob makes a measurement
this one's correct so he correctly gets
the polarization is up here he correctly
gets that it's to the right here down
here he chose the wrong basis but
accidentally got the
um
uh oh wait I haven't uh okay nice
uh
this is just a copy of what was sent so
sorry I shouldn't have quite said that
so we the ones that he got about half of
them wrong well he has to figure out
which half he got raw okay
so this is the interesting part
Alice publicly announces
the basis that he used for each one
through this public Channel
tell everybody even Eve
she says I used z x z x z z x x z x okay
but she doesn't say which bit she was
encoding that is she says it's Z but she
doesn't say whether it was up or down
arrow
she says it's X but she doesn't say
whether it's left Arrow or right arrow
okay
now Bob as soon as he hears the public
announcement of her basis choices he
knows which measurements he did that
were wrong
like here she said this was an accident
he accidentally used a z so he just
drops that he discards that he discards
all the ones that are wrong
okay and it's okay that Eve knows this
is that clear
all right then
Bob is now going to check if there's an
eavesdropper
okay he wants to Bob Alice publicly
announces
among so Bob says
um tells Alice which ones he's thrown
away and which ones he happened to use
the right measurement and then Alice
Picks a small subset of those that he
got right so let's say this one
that one and she publicly announces
the actual uh uh bit value that she sent
or the qubit polarization
okay
and Bob checks if he got the same thing
if he got the same thing then it's
probably true that there's no
eavesdropper because everything matched
up if there's an eavesdropper she would
have corrupted it randomly because she
also has to guess whether to measure in
X or Z
okay it's not guaranteed but if if this
is a string of a hundred thousand bits
and Alice uses up 30 of them for Bob to
compare the chances of getting uh
failing to detect the use dropper in 30
tries is very very small
all right I don't know if that's fully
grasp why that is like how why is it
that it Alice checks the the qubit with
Bob that that would enable them to know
if there's well I'll I'm going to
explain that separately I'm just kind of
giving you the what why he's doing it
okay I'll answer that in a second
okay
so
uh okay so now
uh they've they've publicly announced
these bit values so they can't use those
uh but all the remaining ones
like here Bob used to made the correct
measurement has correctly gotten the
zero that she sent but nobody else
except Alice and Bob know that
because there's no eavesdropper they've
eliminated that possibility so they
first entry in the secret key
is what
and then here it's a sorry a zero then
it's one
here's a zero and here's a one
so you that you send many Quantum bits
and you get a little less than half of
them as your secret key and then you use
it just like a one-time pack
you you this is just the secret key in
the one type pad where Alice can now
send on the public uh Channel per
encrypted message and Bob has the secret
key to decrypt it
and it can be sent publicly and Eve can
hear it but she doesn't know what to do
all right so uh so we're gonna we're
gonna do this exercise now with assuming
there's no eavesdropper and uh uh you're
gonna break up into teams uh four in the
in the sheets you will choose uh I'll do
it on that side so they can actually see
me uh and the first key you will choose
a random string of zero and one either
putting a coin or just writing them then
you would choose your anchoring basis of
X or Z and then you will do the
conversion of polarization and then same
thing you will have using this table yes
uh and then you will have Michelle
measurements who will come in and
compare if it's the same base that Bob
picks you will get the same uh Direction
and if it's a different one with flip a
coins and writes the wrong one and then
you reconvert that and hopefully you
will have the code you can compare how
much is that okay so just to review what
we just did Alice Alice Picks a uh
classical bit string
randomly
encoding bases randomly
figures out what qubits to send from
that
then uh announces publicly just the
basis choice not the arrow directions or
the big values Bob eliminates the ones
where he measured incorrectly then among
the remaining ones where Bob is sure he
should agree with Alice because he
measured in the same basis they publicly
compare a few
and since there was no eavesdropper in
this example they should agree on those
few and say oh there's no eavesdropper
and then get rid of those and the
remaining ones in this case one these uh
one zero one and zero are the secret key
okay
uh he he chose the right basis to
measure so he should have gotten the
same thing that Alice sent but if
they're different
then they've detected the presence
they've either made a mistake which does
happen or they've detected the presence
of an eavesdropper and they called the
protocol okay the key isn't used to send
the cryptogram and the secret is safe
although Bob doesn't know what it is
they have to try again later
now why does the eavesdropper
perturb the quantum channel change the
state
that Bob is receiving well because just
like Bob she doesn't know which basis in
which to measure to find out what Alice
sent so she guesses randomly and uh when
she guesses X and Alice is sending uh in
the Z basis she changes the results
okay just like the problem that Bob had
but uh
uh so when she passes it on to Bob in
order to hide her presence
she has changed the results but this
protocol lets Bob and Alice compare
notes publicly and see if if each uh for
turkey
it's a very clever protocol that
involves it's secure even though it
involves Public Communication
all right so we're gonna try it again
and some of the groups
are going to have an eavesdropper and
some of the groups are not and we know
which is which we're going to tell you
and then you guys are going to go
through the exercise and tell us whether
you think there's an eavesdropper
okay so it's the same uh the same
exercise
but if Bob and Alice don't agree on the
ones that they select
you have to assume there's an Easter you
could get unlucky and not find out
there's a new strawberries uh the uh
the probability the failure probability
if uh Bob and Alice sacrifice n of the
bits to see if they got the same result
the probability of failure is
three-fourths to the end
when if n is 30 that's one chance in ten
thousand that you would miss the
eavesdropper if it's n is 50 it's
so assuming you can send hundreds of
qubits it's not a problem
it's not guaranteed but it's
exponentially unlikely that you missed
the eavesdropper you you're my group of
four so the test would be Alice Bob Eve
and Michelle so you all have a mission
Alice and Bob needs to make an effort
not hear what Michelle and uh Eva during
in the middle so we'll try to stay in a
corner like try not to look too much at
what they're doing
um each paper are numbered so you will
have group one group two and so what
we're going to do is all the alices will
be line up here all the ball will be
lining here hopefully you try to like
aim and recognize who's your above and
then Alice and Eve who can oh sorry
Michelle and Eve would be in the middle
during the actual transaction
um I have a list of crucifying on who
um so I'll tell you that based on your
group number
um we were talking about uh a little bit
earlier about how some keypad get lost
um I have the solution here I've lost it
in the room for five minutes we didn't
know what it was for a bit so like no
matter how much encryption you do stupid
error Newman error will be also done
follow all this encryption because we've
lost the pads uh four feet so you could
have find it and
spy on us
and then the last thing
um we have is a sheet of questions
um so basically
um we're asking three questions the
first one is how many of bug bases match
alices so we want to see like if you had
five six okay uh how many bits do did
you reveal perfectly so this is where
you can gamble you can either take just
one two three as many as you want and
then you have to figure out if you are
if you detect this robot so at the end
we want to know if you've been spy on
and how many bits you can have right and
then the more bit values you publicly
reveal so that Bob can check if it got
for financial
the more likely you are to detect the
eavesdropper
but fewer bits you have left for your
secret key so that's the trade-off
if you're feeling lucky you can just
stop
correct yeah
um
so we went through the whole process and
hopefully we did it correctly in a way
that you didn't know if he was spying on
you or not uh so what happened is that
she probably had between four and six
bits that are correct in the string and
then you had to choose between one two
three a couple of bits that you can
compare
um so I'm gonna call we're gonna call my
order the uh the group and figure out
who I was fine on so I'm gonna call
where's group one yeah so let's have
um let's have uh Bob Bob he's usually
the one we'll call it the final because
Alice knows what uh what they sense okay
group one uh who's Bob one
were you spying or not when I guess or
whatever yeah what do you think I guess
no no not spied on well you were yeah
so that's the risk and that's why we
have the properties
I don't think so no you were not correct
uh group three book three okay will you
spot on them yes you were and that was
an interesting case here because uh they
they compare the first Biz and it was
the same and they was like oh we don't
spite on and if they had stuck here
if you could have done the information
I'm like no let's try another one and
then the second beats were wrong and so
that's why they needed this fight on
okay uh group number four four spiral or
not I decided not
that's correct nobody listened to you uh
group five but five
yes a spider yes you're correct uh and I
think we had another six maybe yeah uh
group six so you Spyder or not yes
oh okay
oh my God
um
right I think okay uh but that's a good
example on like it's much easier to
discard the whole key if you have a
doubt then uh just using it right right
okay super thanks for it so here's the
last slide this is just to illustrate
for you this in Real uh a real
experiment
uh uh so China has this amazing uh
misses uh satellite in orbit about uh
four years ago I think 2018
and
um they have these uh uh telescopes
which uh follow the satellite and lasers
which send photons individual photons up
to the satellite which uh that sends
them back down in this case to Vienna to
uh Anton zeilinger's uh lab in Vienna
Anton is who I won the Nobel Prize this
year for uh work on uh quantum
entanglement which is kind of the
background behind this
and uh they were able to send uh it's a
moving satellite you know it's a small
Target that you got to send photons up
and hit the detector there and so forth
it's pretty complicated
and uh they were able to send a few
thousand
secret bits which were then used to
encode uh a phone call between the
president of Anton is the president of
the Austrian and the cabinet Sciences
the president of the Chinese Academy of
Sciences here's a little uh animation
yeah okay there we go so there's the
satellite coming up over the horizon
here's the laser beam from the telescope
you see the Dome turning as it goes this
is a kind of time lapse thing that's why
it's uh
a stretch down like that very very
technologically complex
to send individual photons up to this
thing that's moving 18 000 miles an hour
and then have it be able to send others
down from space to
uh to Vienna so this is the current
state of the art in this technology it's
also been used in optical fiber uh uh
there's a a company in Europe County
could Nikolai she's there founded that
has done tests between Banks and
switzerlands and they've encrypted bits
through optical fiber over tens of
kilometers this is the light the
advantage of uh using the satellite is
you only have to go through a thin layer
of the atmosphere right yeah so there's
a very very thin it's just a few miles
of air and then you go through backing
the disadvantages you got to hit that
Target in most of the photons yes so
they have to do this many times
but and then optical fiber is amazing
you can send light through it for
several kilometers without much of it
being absorbed but if you want to send
it across the Pacific
uh you have to have amplifiers that can
keep it going those amplifiers ruin the
class of the quantum part it make it
classical so it's you have to build
something called a Quantum repeater and
we haven't we're learning how to do that
now it's very very hard so still very
early days for the technology but these
these this particular encoding you know
is an actual years it actually works so
I hope you had fun and and learned a few
things thank you so much
[Applause]